and the next day i let the girl's
boyfriend know what happened and he
straight up wanted to scrap
yo yo welcome back to the
757th edition of sng
um um we're 400 years old and
we're having a good time we're having a
great time having a great time so you
may or may not have noticed that we were
wearing
some lavish attire today something
different something a little different
just a little mix up just a little
one-off just
spruce up for you man today it's
obviously it's february
the uh the month of love 14th
you know how it is you know the vibes um
every day the 14th that's also um that's
on the love below album
happy valentine's day love below that's
such an underrated album i'm pretty sure
me and toby the only ones that like that
one
toby likes every year he does he does
like everybody he's very eclectic when
it comes to yeah
valentine's day is the valentine's month
um before we decided to you know add
something new to the collection it's a
one-off for the month so
have a look on the website you can see
jimmy's rocking the sng heartbreak
smt heartbreak i'm rocking the send news
text so you know
hey see what you feel see what your
fancy obviously all the different colors
available
before we give you something nice give
you something back yeah man so enjoy
that this is literally like you said
it's a one-off guys so
this this much isn't going to be going
for any longer than february yeah so
it's only for one month guys jump in
enjoy jump on the heartbreak vibes you
know how it is we've been through it
everybody wants news obviously follow
one of the centers
run the nudes and help us through the
heartbreak man that's what we do
that's what we do for one another that's
the relationship we have you send us in
your issues
we resolve them send nudes
that's it man it's a win-win this is the
relationship we have and now we just
want to put it on the top
so there you go man enjoy the the
valentine's one-off special edition
merch
yeah um but yeah um
whatever man that's oh obviously patreon
i'm not gonna i was thinking they know
what to do but nah nah nah nah nah nah
nah
nah let me remind let me remind you man
patreon patreon jump on the patreon
that's where the good vibes are
always um as soon as we wrap up this
recording we are about to jump in
to the patreon recording and it's gonna
get saucy juicy
it's going to get juicy we've got some
topics i've already got some toppings i
want i'm saving for that one and if you
want to be a part of that
you know what to do a day
now tell them again for the [ __ ] in
the back tell them again for the people
in the back
from me my pizza pound a month 10
p a day run me my pee
it's that simple it's literally that
should be at the back of your t-shirt
it's that simple people run me my pee
it's normal cause
but yeah man we appreciate all the love
so far as always thank you guys thank
you guys for supporting us
um but yeah let's get straight into it
um so the fun fact today i might butcher
a story but
i wanted to do it differently whereas as
opposed to just reading a fun fact
yeah you've actually studied a fun fact
you studied it yeah so now you know the
details so i know more details juicy
yeah
juicy juicy um so do you know who
i'm sure you do and i'm sure most people
that are listening or watching know who
this person is
theodore roosevelt as president yeah so
he was the
26th i think i've written that note down
i can't remember because i don't want to
butcher his
actual accolade he was the 26th
president of the united states of
america
um so there's a story behind him that he
him and his boys
i'm probably gonna butcher anyway but
it's fun him and his boys went on a
hunting trip once
hunting trip one time um and what they
used to do with they used to hunt bears
apparently um so all let's say that for
example there was five or six of them
um the four of them all hunted bears all
got their kill whatever but man like
theodore couldn't get one
um and he had uh i think he had a slave
or like a
it wasn't necessarily a slave or someone
that worked for him at the time
probably anyway speak
probably safe work from at the time and
he had found one for him so he caught
apparently he cornered the bear tied him
to a tree
and it was like big man i've got a bear
for you so you could shoot so you could
be part of the gang obviously
because that he's a he was an avid
hunter as well
yeah um but man like theodore said this
is on sportsman like it's not fair yeah
it's not even ground
yeah but and he never shot the bear so
apparently this spread like wildfire
over all of obviously he's the president
so anything he does
is gonna get is gonna spread so he um
they put it all over the newspapers and
was like ah theodore roosevelt
doesn't want to shoot a bear and
a cartoonist caught wind of it and made
into a cartoon sketch on the newspapers
just for shits and gigs pun intended um
and then
there was a couple that own i think they
owned a candy store or
sweet shop but they also made stuffed
animals
so what they did was they hollered him
to create a stuffed bear and
used asked for his name see if they can
um patent the bear with his name
and obviously what's the other short
form dear and another one
go on go on go on there's probably
people screaming are you gonna say
ted teddy so he i was like
i jumped in there like theo
yeah so yeah yeah
shame that's embarrassing theo
obviously i'm speaking what bears called
theo cars ted
ted so yeah they patent patented
that from his name and he that was the
invention of the teddy bear
bravo and i was in 90 around 1902 in
mississippi
i've always wondered why a teddy bear is
called a teddy bear
i say wondered i've never really thought
about too much otherwise i just googled
it
but it's always something that's like
why is it called a teddy yeah that's the
reason why i saw the teddy bear
interesting that's pretty cool
i like that one that was very cool thank
you very much you're welcome and you're
welcome guys you don't see you every day
like i say
speaking of presidents
now i know we all hate trump yeah
everyone does yeah
we have to rate him in it give me
context before i say yes or no
say yes and then i'll tell you what no
no no no no no give me context and i'll
say yes or no no
i probably know what you mean because i
know you so probably yes yes i have to
respect
his how do i say
dan bilzerian like nature oh of course
of course just like the way danville
zirin
lives the way if you ask any teenage guy
if you won the lottery tomorrow what
would you do that's literally done by
zero's life
the way trump ran his presidency was
literally like if you asked
a 10 year old what would you do if
you're a president that's what that's
what you do
scattered the whole thing yeah he
man was just out here pardoning rappers
for what just because it's his last day
just because it's his last day man's
letting man out a pen
just all you man come on come on come on
come on i'm president
what a sick move not that i give a [ __ ]
about the rappers being out yeah yeah
yeah
but just as like a i'm such a kid i'm a
78 year old kid wherever however old he
is yeah
i'm just like i shouldn't be present
like i'm just
contin he's like it's almost like i'm
waiting for him to come out and be like
just so you know yeah this was all a
massive ploy
to prove how stupid people of this
planet are
the fact that i've done nothing for the
fast however many years
but act like an absolute [ __ ] and i keep
getting away with it
to the point where in my last days of
presidency i'm just letting man out a
pen
he like we said in a comment which
episode it was like he's got the biggest
balls
like the biggest he's got such bravado
because he can do stuff and get away
with it he doesn't care
do you remember there's another random
fun fact um i was
do you know when you go on you just
googling stuff for example and you go
down a rabbit hole on wikipedia
have you ever done that and you just
start search for something
and you click someone else's name and
you click so yeah you keep reading that
and read yeah yeah
i was doing that the other day yeah so
i'm an avid
uh man united fan and it was it's not
only until
this current pandemic that actually sat
down to watch football a lot
because um obviously well the people
that know what i do
i work most weekends and that's
obviously when football is playing most
weekends
um but i was watching i've been watching
football a lot more this
this pandemic and fallen in love with it
completely again
i'm a united fan and for some reason i
was
watching uh i think i was watching an
nfl game it was the game
before where does um tom brady play for
now is it a buccaneers
uh tampa yeah i think yeah so it was
that game the championship
um for that game so they had won their
whatever it was before the
the super bowl that's that's yeah yeah
yeah yeah um and the owner is a glazer
and the glaze glazer is the owner of
united as well
yeah so glaze is the glaze's own united
so i was reading through his um history
because
i recognize anyone thinking glaze i'm
sure that's the same tony that owns
united or the same family that owned man
united
um so i was reading through his
wikipedia or whatever and it got to a
point where
before the glazers owned my united or
owned a
massive share of vietnam united there
were other people that are bidding for
it as well
and then there was a guy you know you
know
that max gillane maxwell oh
yeah epstein's epstein's yeah yeah so
her father
was in the runnings for owning man
united and i was thinking that name
rings a bell
and then i clicked his name and he said
one of her kids was gillane and he's
like what
it's a mad yeah i don't think how crazy
that is yeah because
all of these elite bedrooms isn't it all
of them are bedridden
that's why people are out here saying
epstein's boys of all of you
because you can go on wikipedia and just
find the connection find the connections
yeah that's mad do you not think because
when you just go through a rabbit hole
you find so many loopholes not
necessarily loopholes but so many
weird connections yeah you realize that
you literally do realize that that's
like
there's all these billionaires are
bredrins of course there's no two ways
about it of course
there's so few of them that they're all
boys um
but yeah it's [ __ ] mad that is that
is wild trump's
lost his mind he's gonna die in prison
probably
but up to this point he's just been like
[ __ ] whatever brother he what you
he's a big kid he is a huge kid and
boris is done boris did one move this
weekend
that made me realize that like you're a
[ __ ] what do you do
i thought he would i didn't know if he i
didn't know he was certibitch yeah but
he's a [ __ ] now
like you know have you seen that
obviously they've banned
flights coming home from dubai yes so
man said you're not coming over and
dubai
yes obviously they're blaming on like i
haven't read into it but like the south
african
strain there's a this is another strain
okay south africa and they don't want it
yes
yes yes yes yes yes but like just
the the wording and the phrasing of the
thing and
basically like the way it's gone
is in that like basically ah let me get
your contacts away i'm just rambling
put it in context so if you're not from
the uk this is this will help you
understand
so basically the uk shot is we we
basically weren't allowed to go anywhere
in europe europe said you're not coming
if you're from the uk you ain't coming
in because
every man is out in the uk just [ __ ]
and sucking
and everyone's got arona so these man
said you've invaded your own
super gonorrhea strain yeah you're not
coming here so we're like cool and dubai
was like come come come
dybala was
we got you bro bring your tits in your
wallet let's go
we got your eyes open come through so
everyone was like [ __ ] it you can't keep
me here i'm gonna do what i want i'm
gonna go to dubai
and then everyone to dubai lived up
lavish um
and boris was vexed boris was just like
nah nah
nah nah that's not what we're doing here
yeah we're trying to
be responsible all these influences
first of all i hate the term influences
and if i can ever get away without
saying that word then i will
but all the influences i do by just
living it up and everyone was vexed
so instead of even wording it in a way
that
like was just like oh as a way to be
more responsible
all flights from such and such will
be i don't even know but these are the
these are the regulations that we need
to put in place to protect ourselves
from this
instead of actually just making a big
song and about it like they usually do
man just turned around and said without
warning without warning
management around and said if you come
about from dubai you're not allowed
no way if you're in the base he said if
you're in dubai stay there
if you love dubai so much why do you
live there ma said if you'd love to buy
it much live there forever because
you're not allowed home
you waste man who's laughing now that's
boring
he's vex he's literally so angry the man
said
you're not allowed home from dubai
actually stay there
if you love it so much [ __ ] stay
there he's probably like i don't
i'm not a politics person whatsoever
like i don't really follow politics i
don't really get involved because
it's just not something i've been
interested in for my whole life
but boris johnson is just
an idiot like he's an absolute player
because
obviously he was the one that so what
the strain has been going on or this has
been going on for over a year now
around about a year now and he was the
same guy that said oh don't worry shake
hands oh don't worry oh early doors
in everyone and he put himself in
hospital
he's on his deathbed as soon as he went
into hospital well as soon as they said
oh he's got the road
i was like oh my god he was up in
hospital with lips and
shaking oh he's a fool but another thing
about him sorry to cut you off another
thing about him i hate the fact that
he can be our prime minister with that
head top like
his hair so do something about it is the
most
it's it's the biggest slap in the face
to anyone in this planet yeah saying
that
you can you can be what you want like
oh how do i even put this in words [ __ ]
it oh it's so annoying it's so
because i know you mean i'm picturing
these hair tops i know you're thinking
there are companies on your business in
this place was like
your hair isn't acceptable but our prime
minister that's what we want has this
mop on his head yeah and he's allowed to
be on tv
he doesn't even acknowledge it
he wakes up and just cracks up just gets
on with it he's stylish just says yeah
you look good today from day
crackling when he was mayor of london
from earliest oh he's always been like
that
it's so jarring that he's allowed to be
yeah yeah it's it's a mad thing as well
i've always said as well like i couldn't
i couldn't do that job as much stick as
he gets and stuff like that
i physically because you can't in this
scenario you can't win
you cannot win have we ever had a
promise of what everyone was like gang
to my knowledge not i don't know i don't
think so it was always vex myself of
course
of course of course but i feel like as
well
there there could be a place where you
can because obviously um i feel like is
it in new zealand and somewhere else
where
they're like rona free because their
prime ministers or presence or whatever
they've got in their countries
are women presidents or prime ministers
and they locked off the borders from the
jump no one's going in
no one's going out everyone's taking
full precaution and now they can't
it's true this is the thing with me
though this is
this is like a really weird tipping
point for me that i like
looked into and stuff like that because
it's the same with like new zealand
so sweden and new zealand are basically
rona free
but people don't also take into
consideration that yes they locked off
their borders
but as soon as they open their borders
they'll all get rona if you know what i
mean obviously now we have a vaccine
that's less likely
but there are also two countries that
don't rely
on um like in the intermixing of
like england we need we haven't we're in
[ __ ] little island in the middle of
nowhere we need everyone else we need
everyone to come out yeah
yeah yeah we need to get our food from
everywhere else we need to get
everything like a tiny little island in
whereas there's other countries that
aren't necessarily they don't live like
that they're
they're more self-sustained yeah as it
is okay um
which is why agreed they took certain
steps that were better than our initial
steps
but also it's a case of
how do i explain it yeah one we rely on
our
connections with other countries to
survive and two
we like to see ourselves as
we like to see ourselves as one of the
top-down countries
of wealth we are which makes
you can see why our politicians would
assume that we're better than them
so what sweden's doing
and what new zealand's doing we don't
pay attention to
what america's doing what china's doing
what the other big dons are doing
that's what we pay attention to even
though that has [ __ ] all to do with
anything
um and you can kind of see
it's again it's like a rock and a hard
place thing like granted
they cut off their borders from jump
from jump
yeah but obviously i don't really know
the
economics like that
the economic strain could have been
dire if we just locked off our borders
from day one oh i'm pretty sure it would
have been
and a lot of people would have been and
then the la the
the the kickback would have been way way
way worse than it's already been
if he'd locked up everything and then i
don't know for example fishermen have
all left their jobs
the the like no one's getting food in
the country we're all living our [ __ ]
baked beans
because we can't get anything yeah no
one's getting any new like
new technology or nothing nothing is
coming into the country enough is coming
out of the country
like we can't survive yeah then
regardless of swede no one would be
saying like he wouldn't have a good
enough excuse
then if he did that but we're all
running free but we're all starved
if he then went on tv and said oh
well i did it because new zealand did it
and they're running free and so are we
everyone would have murdered him because
people would say i'd rather have the
[ __ ] rhona
than staff to death yeah okay does that
make sense of course it makes sense it's
like a rock and a hard place obviously
i'm not ready i'm not seeing him
yeah he's a [ __ ] but again i'm also
thinking
who wouldn't be a [ __ ] in this situation
because like a lot of people are getting
stick
but it's again like i said it's like a
rock and hardware situation whatever
decision you make
there's also an equal and opposite
reaction to that decision that has
nothing anything any step you put in
place to protect people from rona
the has an equal and opposite reaction
that has nothing to do with rona yeah so
for example your position
to protect people from rhona they close
all the restaurants so people are like
yay
no rona but then people who work in
restaurants
are like i'm poor do you know what i
mean yeah and like and restaurants
people who own restaurants are like i'm
literally in hundreds of thousands of
hours a day yeah
you're not letting me open yeah so it's
a weird one but then again it's a case
of
okay cool open all the restaurants
and then the nhs gets flooded with
roanoke people
the thing with that um the eat out to
help out was the biggest the biggest
dumbest biggest dumbest cause
like obviously i understood the cause as
to why he did or why they did er
telepathic
so comey but it's the logistics of it
fam
did you did you go to restaurants during
that period or no uh i went to
one but i remember on the first day that
it banged yeah there was a queue
outside of mcdonald's around the corner
family
every day like let me give you content
if you've never worked in hospitality or
if you've never
actually been to restaurants during like
december period
because december is the busiest period
for every restaurant going obviously
because
it's christmas period you get um
families you get from
businesses coming in blah blah so
obviously that's where everyone makes
the most money
but the er tail part was it in august it
was still hot i remember that
every day felt like christmas bro or
christmas period it was the
busiest time i've ever worked i remember
the first day we opened
we opened on july 4th yes that day was
wednesday because it wasn't yeah about
then but it was obviously the first day
we had
i was sweating buckets nah and then
after that was august was help
and then they were saying oh it could
potentially extend to
september thinking oh god please now
please no bro
i was busy for those of you that don't
understand eat out to help out was a
scheme that was put in place after the
restaurants have been closed for so long
to help the restaurant industry get back
on its feet the government uh
implemented a discount for anyone who
goes to eat in a restaurant
they get a discount and the government
would subsidize the rest of the rest
and it's a maximum of 10 pound per
person what was it 50 off
yeah a maximum of ten pounds maximum
tampon yeah so yeah
so you could get fifty percent off a
meal at a maximum of ten pound discount
yeah so
meal costs 20 pounds you'll get um
ten pound off if you've got 21 pounds
you're still getting 10 pounds off if
you've got 30 pounds you still getting
10 pounds
was it per person so let's say me you
went out for food and our bill was 100
pound we'd get 20
off the bill yeah exactly yeah cool but
the clause in there was
is that you had to eat inside the
restaurant for it to be applicable yeah
so takeout didn't didn't count
so everyone went to eat inside and
everyone was mixing we've just been
locked down for months for months and
then everyone's rushing all into
restaurants
and then his answer because it all
[ __ ] up was to just close all the
restaurants again
and it was it was proven that
restaurants aren't even the biggest
cause
oh yeah i know it was just yeah
restaurant one is annoying so there's
don't get me wrong i'm not defending
buyers he's a waste man
but there's definitely dumb dumb dumb
[ __ ] like that our table i think that is
just categorically dumb
it doesn't make sense whereas other
stuff i can kind of see where it's just
like
i can understand why everyone's vex say
did that but if you did the opposite to
that
it the cause and effect of of that
decision could have potentially been
as bad if not worse in other
economically
yeah then it would be like corona wise
and it's always tough again
depend on your outlook is always
dependent on your
um how
how risky it is for you to get it do you
know what i mean so for us it's
hardly risky so i'm more concerned about
things that affect my day-to-day life
with the risk of rhona involved yeah
yeah yeah whereas if i was an 85 year
old woman
then i'll be a bit more inclined to be
like yeah that decision makes sense
i'm trying to protect myself i can see
why he's doing that i can see what i'm
doing i'm thinking about my best
interest
you have no choice but to always kind of
even if you don't think you are you kind
of always think about what's best for
you yeah of course
so yeah i can understand some of the
decisions other times they benefit
other people but again it's like a weird
one it's like a super controversial
topic but it's just like
at a point it's not going to go anywhere
ever it's always going to be around
to a degree so obviously vaccines are
rolling out and things like that and
it's just like
i don't like that they they rarely
disclose the percentage of people of
deaths
that are from like uh because obviously
the biggest cause
is like care homes and stuff right
but they don't always release the stats
okay of what percentage we're talking
about i just care home people
okay because if i like if for example it
could be like 98
okay but then if it's 98
and you came out and said oh 98 we've
got like 3 000
deaths today but 98 of them are from
care homes and everyone just be like
that's a no-brainer open up everyone and
just knock it in the kitchen
which obviously they can't do yeah so
obviously i can see why there's a little
bit of haze
it's the haze that i'm not a fan of yeah
because there's a public because
that's when it gets political because at
the end of the day
he makes all the decisions which is for
obviously like for the best of
um best interest best interest of
everyone yeah but really it's about
what's the best interest of
for him politically what decisions so if
any time he makes a decision or decides
to release a certain
piece of information or not will be
based on if there's any information
you're hiding it's always going to be
best on
how does this make me look yeah if i
tell everyone that 99.9 percent of
people that are dying are from camps i'm
not saying they are obviously
what i'm saying for example of that if i
come out everyone and say we're in a
national lockdown
because of all these deaths but then 99
of the deaths are from people in care
homes
how's that going to make me look like
because that has holding back that
information benefits
no one by himself um so that's stuff
that i get frustrated about
but um at the end of the day we're just
we're just living in a covered world now
in it
you've got to do what you do living in a
covered world we're living in a covered
world
yeah living in a covered world i was
actually thinking about this the other
day
in that like from 20 years from now
we're like you'll bump into someone
who's like 20 years old
and they're like what's oh i don't know
um
13th of the 4th 2020 and you're like oh
you're a kofi baby
that's what it is someone says their
birthday is 20 20 are you a copy baby
baby
weird oh that is very that's going to go
on forever forever yeah
it's gonna be history books and [ __ ] wow
we are actually a part of history yeah
this is actually a part of history
that's crazy it is interesting when you
think about it that way like you're
looking back like 100 years from now
they'll be like oh what happened in 2020
wasn't 2020 always meant to be like a
weird year and not necessarily covered
wise but the actual year 2020 wasn't
meant to be like a
uh super conspiracy kind of year
probably fam i think every 20 years of
[ __ ] conspiracy 2000 was supposed to
be a conspiracy
as well 2012 and let's be confused i
don't know why but yeah that's
so weird that's so so weird um
i've got a scenario for you yeah man so
let's say we're all out it's us it's the
fellas me you
um jay rem tobes we're at a function
party's going we're chilling like it's
it's normal times now it's not what
we're talking
about we're not talking about rounder
times we're talking about normal normal
times normal times yeah we're at a
function
music's going there's women there's
vibes we're getting money
get money get money yeah yeah so we're
doing that we're chilling chilling and
chilling
for some reason you're telling me oh by
the way fellas i need to go toilet and
i'm like i don't know what you're
telling me go piss anyway yeah you go
yeah so you walk into the toilet now
you're the only one in there obviously
well not obviously but you're the only
one in there and then you hear someone
coming behind you about
probably about 10 seconds later but
you're by this point you're ready at the
urinal you're doing what you have to do
but you hear the door lock
but you you're not too sure it is but
you you know the sound the sound is
familiar to you
so you're thinking that's a bit strange
you continue doing what you're doing
still pissing you're still pissing you
do what you have to do
and then one one brayer pisses like
three
cubicles next to you or three urinals
next to you so you're not like close so
it's not weird it's not
but he's wedge you look at him and you
think [ __ ] he's big
so just i'm looking down and i just look
over like that and then i'm thinking
jesus [ __ ] he's stacked yeah stacked
don't
you look it's tall or nice don't look
it's too long no no no no no it's not
that nice nothing like that
but you're just looking you just notice
there's a big he's a big breath i look
it's tall there
that's where this is going right come on
i know the game
he's locked the door he's massive i
might as well look at the tool now
because i'm probably going to be tasting
it in a minute
that's how this story sounds
let me finish this all right go go go go
go go go that's hilarious
that's how this story sounds so you're
looking at him whatever whatever
and then you go off and wash your hands
no he finishes before you
cool that's not uncommon i piss for ages
he finishes before you so he goes to
wash his hands and by the time he's like
drying and stuff
you're washing your hands and he's like
sorry to
like sorry this might seem a bit awkward
a bit weird but it's like
i've seen you in the function and i
think you're cute oh god someone knew it
i think you're cute i've been watching
you for a minute now got pretty mouth
that's why i came well let me finish cuz
you can't go what is
going on that's why that's why i came in
now because i wanted to ask you
something
and you're obviously you're like what
first you're like crazy like what's
going on yeah
i mean okay what do you want to ask me
kind of thing he's like you don't have
to do anything
but i'd really want to suck you off oh
my god
i really want to suck you off you don't
have to psych me off back
but i really remember i remember he's
massive
yeah yeah yeah he's huge yeah you're
already intimidated oh my god
already intimidating yeah yeah i really
want to suck you off and you're just
like what nah nah nah
fam he puts his hand against the door
slam like bangs his hand against the
door you hear the vibrations i said big
man
i really want i don't think you missed
it
the bass in his voice drops man said i
really want to talk you off bruv
the base in his voice drops you shiver
you shiver what are you doing
you don't have to suck it like he he's
adamant that you don't have to do a
thing to him
but he's like big man you're not leaving
this room until
your tool is in my mouth
nah
i will say cool i'd be
kneeling it i wait he gets on his knees
and i will have to rock him with the
nastiest haymaker i can stomach fam
i need to make sure his cheekbone leaves
his face
he needs to be drooling out of it and he
needs to drop
but that's a risk it is a
risk and the doors are locked locked fab
so it's not one of them once where you
can rock him quickly
i need to fiddle with the thing and then
no my god i'll be sweating
okay okay okay let's say you let's say
this scenario is played out
okay he's on his knees you've rocked him
you're about to dip to the door let's
say there's the distance is a me
two meters yeah wave rocked him and
where the door was yeah yeah you run to
the door
you've grabbed the ting you've grabbed
the handle and you've grabbed the lock
you've unlocked it
but you feel his hand grabbed the back
of your ankle because he's on the floor
remember he's huge so his hand size is
already massive he grabs your ankle
and then he yanks you and i just yanks
like a rag your head smacks the door
you're on the floor now that's a wrap i
don't know where we as and we need to go
from here
it's a wrap i flipped the coin and it
came up tails
it's a wrap ah it's funny because
obviously because prior to that you
would you have told us that you're going
to toilet and
at this point you're knocked out so it's
probably been about 10 minutes
and i see one donny i see the donny
coming out of the toilet like ah
yeah and then i see you about five
minutes later blue eye
just days just dazed gee your belt's
hardly done
oh so hang on after all of this he still
sucked me off
i thought it was a ploy so after all of
that
he knocked me out grabbed me everything
and then unbuttoned my [ __ ]
he didn't i said you're not sucking him
off he was i know but i just thought
that was part of the game
i thought he was just saying that to get
on his good side
i thought if i had to do it then
afterwards he was going to make me do it
anyway no he doesn't he doesn't want
that he's not here for you
he's here for him do you know what i
mean yeah yeah yeah
so he knocks me out and then just
something the only reason why he's done
that is because you rocked him
because he he could have basically it's
the easy way of the harder you chose the
hardware yeah i chose the hard way
i think 10 times out of ten i'm choosing
the hardware oh for sure for sure ten
times that time i'm choosing the hard
way and i need to smash his jaw in
clearly it didn't work that i'd have to
follow up with the left afterwards
sutton he needs to drop
i'll be terrified
terrified that's why i asked you
jesus christ he has to drop
you would run out and come to us for
that fam we need to go i'm running past
you man and i bail you when i'm outside
you man will see me start through the
dance floor
i will ring you when i'm outside you
know do you know what that reminds me of
you know those instagram videos where
you say when you see a black person
running a black person runs right behind
them yeah yeah
yeah so as soon as i see you run i'm
like what's good
i'm gone as well because i don't know
what's happened all i know is that
you've got a toilet and you come out and
you've gotta
dart through it i will knock any [ __ ]
on her face
to get where i need to be i'll be so
scared
you might not come outside and i'm just
holding holding the doorman's hand for
oh my god what horrible experience
ah would you tell us what happened
rags i'd have to tell you i'm not see
when it comes like i like to think
like i'm not a [ __ ] bro but when it
comes to certain situations i would just
tell you
i have no ego about these things a man
tried to suck me off against my will
firm and i had to fight to get out of
there
to be fair you have to explain yourself
because you've just darted everyone out
there
i've tired everyone out the way and i'm
sprinting outside i have to explain
yourself
oh my god i don't know oh a horrible
horrible horrible experience
that took my breath away ah we got a fan
request yes that's what i'm gonna look
for now
sorry [ __ ] it i just need to find it
that actually took my breath away
you make me laugh bro you make me laugh
well done thank you
thank you for that i appreciate it
because if i knew your response anyway
but i just wanted to say it and it's
just oh
it's sweet at me hey i'm a big fan of
the podcast and i have a little question
and
thoughts that i want to hear from you
guys is it me or do you guys feel that
you're talking to a girl and it's going
well and maybe you can see it going
somewhere
someday and all of a sudden the girls
you've been previously speaking to a
while back
all of a sudden want to message you and
show you the attention that they wasn't
giving you in the first place
now here's the question do i somehow
smash all these other things
without catching the attention of the
main chick or do i block them
and air them all and obviously you put
could you keep this anonymous if you
speak if you talk about this on the pod
big man if you've watched this you
clearly know
we've never said anything you've never
said anyone's name that's another pet
peeve
i know it's [ __ ] he just shook though in
it he just shot
i know but like come on when have you
ever said anyone's name
i should say your name now i'm joking
i'm not gonna say it but anyway
yeah what what's your advice from he
says i'm just gonna do a quick recap
um he's feeling the girl he wants to he
wants to pat in this thing he's feeling
a blah blah
um as soon as he's gotten with her as
soon as he's gotten close to getting
with her
all of a sudden the girls that in and
around that he he wanted to pat him
before
all of a sudden he needs dm's hollering
for yeah
his question is would you should he
stick with these guns and stick with the
chick that he wants
or should he run through the phone book
quickly and get all our
system before securing his wife
um i said tough that's a case-by-case
basis gee
it is a case i would stick with the gun
um
me personally i would stick with the
guns and stick with the main thing
stick with the main thing so has he
patented this maintaining yet or he's in
the process of trying
he's in the process so he's saying that
he's he can see it going somewhere one
day and he's talking to this girl he's
feeling her blah blah blah so it's not
like
their boyfriend or girlfriend it's not
you know i mean it's just like okay boom
we can clearly both agree that we're
gonna pack yeah
but whilst he's doing this thing whilst
he's talking to this girl he wants
everyone else
they're all shouting them up they're all
shadows these thoughts can smell
when you're not interested somehow they
can
it happens every time as soon as you're
trying to settle down with someone
the exes all the whatever they all they
all
pop up always always ah
and i've been there but it's frustrating
but i would say keep your eye on the
prize like
there's nothing but sorrow at the end of
those nuts there's literally
nothing but sorrow i don't know anyone
who's ever ran through the phone book
whilst they're trying to pursue a wife
and then being proud of themselves
afterwards
okay i just feel like after every night
you just be like
because it's not the one you're aiming
for in it yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah like
if i'm
if i'm going for gold you can give me
all the silver medals in the world it's
just like what's that that means nothing
to me
there are achievements yes that is
obviously context it's whatever to me
it also depends on whether or not
these chicks that are hollering at him
yes he's not
not necessarily not feeling them anymore
but he's got his eyes set on one girl at
the moment
yeah so let's say for example obviously
he's not giving us a full context of who
these other girls
are so they could be baddies for they
could like
they could have been baddies like he's
been dreaming of a time oh yeah
true and now that he maybe he's he's
popping a bit now or something's
happened where
these hoes have noticed him and they
want a piece of the pie but he's moved
on
and it's like oh i have a clear
opportunity to smash this girl
even though i know i can pattern the one
that i want to be with
yeah i can still smash this girl so
that's where it's a bit techy because we
don't like i said we don't know the
context yeah the full
context yeah and if it's a situation
like that
big man i don't judge whatever you do in
it
because i've been there as well that's
that's that's sticky that is sticky
because that's the kind of
that's the childish man in anyone to to
get
to bang the girls that you always dream
to bang in and then they just pop up at
the
worst time possible which is what always
happens yeah
ah i don't know
because i'm assuming in his head he
probably thinks like if he patterns the
skill that he wants to be with that's
him that's he's done now
you know i mean because this is the girl
that he likes etc and he's probably
never going to get another opportunity
that's what that's what always feels
like i know i know that always feels
like
yeah i know who you would say yeah he's
never going to because he's never going
to get this time opportunity
but he might not he might necessarily
not get the opportunity again with these
chicks
but the opportunity might arise again
with someone else does that make sense
yeah for sure man like and it's i feel
like it's gonna be sweeter
once you if you decide to not smash
these things
and it works out with bae you're going
to think back at all these times i think
it will make you feel like she's the one
even more mm-hmm okay so i went through
hell in high water to sort this
relationship out
and it's patterning and it's working
nice whereas
i don't see it working the opposite way
if it didn't work out with bay
you'll be too gutted to be thinking i
should have [ __ ] all these other girls
yeah yeah yeah
i mean that's a childish mentality yeah
you won't regret
yeah you won't regret not [ __ ] the
tramps that are hitting you up
just because but you will regret
potentially [ __ ] something up
that could be sick just to bust a few
nuts
just have a wank and then read your
message again
that's
have a wank read the message you sent us
again and then come to your own
conclusion and then after that if you
still think
no i actually still want to run through
these hoes then maybe she's not the wife
of you
maybe she's not the one you thought she
was but again these are all scenarios
that we probably don't know whether
they're true or not so we're just
potentially speculating they're
speculating we're doing the best we can
we're
we're going what the context we've got
and probably trying to add our own
context but
i'm assuming you get i completely agree
with james as well like i feel like
you should stick completely stick with
your guns also
i think age matters as well obviously i
don't know how old you are um
but if you feel like you've found the
one i'm happy for you bro
but within the same breath you should
always um not necessarily
uh how do i put it whoever you think the
one
may or may not be know whoever you think
the one may be might not
eventually be the one at the end of the
day the one doesn't always stay the one
man
of course had
and you feel like damn this is it i've
i've been in situations where obviously
you know i've been in situations where
i feel like this is it for me like she's
the one and
i'll do anything to try and make sure
she's the one and might try and make
sure that it stays and blah blah blah
and you you don't even not necessarily
look at anyone else but you don't even
entertain
anything not interested bro not
interested because
you're you're hell bent on making this
one work
and obviously i'm happy i had that
mentality and i'm happy that
i stuck with my guns kind of thing but
within the same breath you live and you
learn
as well because now it clearly wasn't
the one because i'm
myself now and i'm single i'm doing what
i want kind of thing but it's
it's also uh it's also a learning curve
stick with your guns my opinion and
james's opinion as well stick with your
guns because
even though it doesn't it might not turn
out to be the one which i hope it is for
you anyway
um it's always going to be a learning
curve because out of every relationship
you learn something new i'll have every
situation you learn something new and if
you take the easy route out i.e which is
[ __ ] all these other girls just to
get the nut because they are craving you
now
back when they weren't craving you um i
feel like it wouldn't be as
sweet as a victory you know yeah of
course not so yeah
i feel like hopefully even though it
wasn't like
the funniest advice it was just like
nail on the head yeah just
go for gold bro go for gold don't really
ever settle no one should ever settle
for silva but
it's obviously only different if you
if she wasn't potentially the one if it
was just a thing you were seeing and
blah blah blah then other
you know what i mean then i would say
but if you're saying she's a thing that
you can potentially see you can
potentially see going somewhere
and by all means man because you never
know what could bite you back in the ass
because let's say
you start patting in this girl now
you're with this girl you get
everything's going great you've been
together a year whatever
but you chose to [ __ ] these other girls
that have been
in your dms for god knows how long just
because they wanted to [ __ ] you
and you did pattern them they could bite
you in the ass like a year down the line
you never know you never know what could
happen
it's better to keep what you've got than
risk it all and yeah
but there you go man that would be my
advice anyway 100 hopefully that helps
i hope i hope that helps
obviously we get we get sent um am i the
[ __ ] and fan requests all the time
and
yes we give our advice but don't take
our advice for gold because if it [ __ ]
up don't come and blame me yeah yeah
yeah yeah i don't want you to be like
i don't want another should i somebody
else over taking fields advice again big
man
you said that to me that day i was like
what bro
i was that was funny also i need to
apologize to not necessarily apologize i
just need to
um i would say apologize actually in a
few episodes ago we were speaking about
um
sex and like uh languages uh what's the
one i'm looking for
we're speaking about oh the accents and
the
languages oh you're on about the german
team yeah yeah yeah yeah so obviously if
if you guys aren't aware or if you guys
haven't seen the episode
i think it was three or two or three
episodes ago we spoke about
what uh what accents are the most
sexiest to us
yeah yeah um during sex uh jimmy said
french
and i think i said spanish um but then i
said oh i
can i can't imagine what german would
sound like because my reference of
german
is just harsh that's why
that's german that's german to me but
i've got no other reference yeah i mean
i only know what i see
or what yeah i'll see you all here on tv
i've never been to germany
so yeah um so someone hit me up a few
people hit me up actually yeah
so one the first person that hit me up
um she was
saying what she gave me a few phrases
and had to completely agree it just
didn't sound sexy at all the first one
that hit me up and she was giving me
she said something like uh she gave me a
phrase that says um either [ __ ] me
harder or
suck my dick or something like that and
it just didn't sound appealing
whatsoever
like i couldn't imagine hearing that or
saying that yeah yeah i was like nah
but another person hit me up and i can't
i don't know what she said
in english but how she said it it might
as well have been spanish
oh okay do you know what i mean yeah and
apparently in germany this is i don't
know don't quote me on this is what she
told me
that um kids call their
parents mommy and puppy the same way
spanish people do
so i'm assuming they not necessarily say
that during sex but it's
it's part of their lingo yeah so they
can say that as well
and when she spoke when she spoke in
german to me
boy the voice no i was like oh okay you
can see it i can see it so fair play
because of that i
i apologize i apologize all right i just
had to get that out of the way
but that's blessed life i'm glad to let
you guys know so
any germans let you let's let you guys
know german is a sexy language it's a
borderline sexy language sometimes it
might sound great
sometimes it might sound bad but yeah
yeah
cool man um are we wrapping up
am i the [ __ ] oh yeah am i the
[ __ ]
sorry sometimes i get mixed up with the
final question by the arseholes
we have to do it i'm at the [ __ ]
if you ain't got one i've got loads bro
i'll go
oh cool oh okay am i the [ __ ]
for letting a threesome go down oh hello
i knew you'd like it
right so me and the boys go to a house
party and all the girls are single
except for one
as the night goes on everyone starts
getting drunk and all the girls
as the night goes on everyone starts
getting drunk and one of the girls
that's single was feeling me and i was
feeding her too
one thing leads to another and me and
this girl me and this girl get down to
the nasty
and as i'm blowing her back out the girl
who has a boyfriend
walks in interesting right
interesting right yes before i can react
she starts
lips in me nah
i'm so sick and tired of repeating
myself where
where are these house parties happening
abroad we've got guys on guys we've got
frustums in relationships we've got all
sorts of these house parties brothers
happening abroad they're not happening
here fam
uk housewives are so dead in comparison
to this
anyway it's frustrating so as soon as i
read it i knew you'd love it i knew
you'd love this one yeah
you're bouncing i'm not bouncing
yeah yeah um before i can react she
starts lips at me
and next thing you know a full-on
threesome is going down it was peg not
gonna lie
this is very [ __ ] up because i've read
this one before and the next day
i let the girl's boyfriend know what
happened and he straight up wanted to
scrap
for the audio listeners for the audio
listeners
um james after i read what i read james
just stood up and left
because clearly you are the [ __ ]
you were an idiot for telling the
boyfriend i've not even finished a thing
let me
let me finish reading it um and the next
day i let the girl's boyfriend know what
happened and he straight up wanted to
scrap
i told him it wasn't that deep because i
know because i know i'd flatten him
but that doesn't but he didn't want to
let it go am i the answer for letting
him know or letting the threesome go
down
love what you guys are doing much love
big man
oh yeah yeah yeah so listen big man i'm
certain
before before i say what i have to say
i'm so happy that you're a fan of the
show
i'm so happy that you you sent us in the
message i'm so glad that you show us the
love and support but come to the come to
studio and scrap me
come to the usual because your bravado
is off the charts
you need no offense fam you need a smack
in the face
you mean to tell me at least i'm sat up
you mean to tell me you smashed next
month's girl
then told him that you smashed his girl
then you're talking chest about yo
you're flirting him
big man i'll knock you out
that's unacceptable absolute behavior
sir i want to keep i want to say polite
that's unacceptable behavior
i will smack the smile your nose guys
if i heard oh say if that happened to
you
and you told me that donny had smashed
your gold and run to you told you about
it
and then said just smack you up so you
bet you basically you need to calm down
yeah cause i'll flatten you anyway cause
we're running to his yard of course we
are of course we are we're at east
location already
big man it got because when i read it i
got as excited as you
yeah it was all juicy threesome this
threesome that with a girlfriend
as well yes and then you had the chest
to tell him
that our big man by the way yesterday i
smashed your girl you know
in the three ways not even in a
three-way not even we got caught up
in a three-way and she was the second
one so you were doing a thing with a
single chick anyway
so why would you tell him that
tell him what what benefit is that for
you
what how does that benefit you and in
power play obviously
that's narcissistic behavior cause you
just wanted to feel like you had
something on him
for no reason you gotta win last night
you got a huge dumb
massive dark broth and you [ __ ] it
you completely fumbled it broth you went
and broke the rules the rules are if
you're gonna smash next man's girl
don't run off and tell him you keep it
shtum you keep it keep the pride inside
your chest
cause that's it because now you and her
know waguan
it's happened it's happened there's no
no she's obviously never gonna tell her
man
and you should obviously hold that same
respect and never tell her man anyway
you could be living like she could have
patted more and more threesomes for you
plus this could have been a thing for
you brother
and you've already you're up here you
started on a
win you started so you were looking down
at my man
and thought he's not low enough you're
on a mountaintop
and you looked down at donny and said
he's not small enough bro let me think
he's great let me dig his [ __ ] grave
and put him under the dirt
let me put him six and when he tries to
defend himself because you've
entered his dms and ruined his day
when he gets a bit crazy about it you
want to put him lower and say big man
it's not even a big deal because i'll
flatten you
i don't the thing is big man
i've never heard such fight in my life
neither have i
apart from the the message one um the
chick that um recorded the recording
getting a smashed out that one
that was fight talk yeah it was fine but
if
my man had told me face to face i think
i would have grabbed anything to stab
him
do you know anything yeah yeah i would
have had a spoon i would stab him
yeah yeah yeah tell me such a thing yeah
you can't brav what's wrong with
like no offense bro what the [ __ ] is
wrong with you you i'll be more mad at
him than my girl
like that he yes my girl disrespected me
don't get me wrong i know people have
you
know
yes yes i talk to her but don't she went
down that's that's neither here nor
there i can move on
yeah yeah it's the fact that you had the
balls to tell me this to my face
and say you would flatten me on top of
it i don't
care i'm flattening you and we're
scrapping
we have to we have to see okay if you
flatten me like
your nose is done we have to you've put
me in a position where i've got no
choice but to fight whether i lose my
life yeah
you're losing something i've got
everything i have as a man
dictates this moment right now if i walk
away from this
without sparking you i'm not a man i'm
not a man you're a [ __ ]
you're literally he was living his life
and you've then put his manhood on the
line for no good reason ruined his day
for no good reason cuz why would you do
that
and then you have to audacity to ask us
if you're an [ __ ] for it
man said am i the [ __ ] for telling
him or smashing the girl
everything and above what are we doing
what are we talking about we raised you
no offense who raised you crazy
oh big man it scan on what is going
on i was so excited at the beginning of
that fam
i was really [ __ ] excited was i so
was i because i knew as soon as i read
it my eyes widened when i read it the
first time
i read it a while ago then when i read
the ending i think
what do you expect us to say
like what do you expect us to say
see you next week i'll see you there
brother you ruined it you ruined the
whole pod for everyone
say thank you for ruining everyone's
monday ruin everyone's monday bro
for god's sake